hello I'm here with Jess and we have
some exciting news she just got to take
a look at 15 minutes of Star Wars
Outlaws we're gonna break that down
right now so we've heard about the Star
Wars game for a very long time but we
haven't seen it until now so what what
exactly is Star Wars Outlaws we play KVs
and you're infiltrating this this sort
of
enemy
at the very Outpost yeah
yeah
um and so you're sneaking around through
there you have your little
sort of like furry oxado toy type
creature you know Star Wars is what we
saw in the trailer right that little
that little creature thing yes okay that
is NYX
um and so you can use NYX to kind of
cause distractions throughout you know
your infiltrations you can send them off
to hit a button and make a noise or
fetch some like ammo or a gun for you
you can do that as well
um so in this gameplay that I saw uh she
sends him to go hit a button and he
moves this crate attached to a crane
um and she ends up jumping on it and
then that way she can ride it to the
other side to kind of get past people
stealthily however she also packs a
punch so you know you see her sneak up
and take down enemies you are equipped
with a blaster she ends up getting a
rifle Blaster during this bit of
gameplay also in the midst of this
infiltration Mission though she ends up
being caught and she has to kind of make
a quick getaway uh runs outside jumps on
a Speeder Bike you get to actually do
combat on the speeder bikes as well so
okay yeah shooting as you're driving and
stuff okay yeah and there's kind of like
this um time slow down element to it
also so you can kind of like you know
lean to one side and time slows down and
you can hit a few enemies pretty quickly
then heads to a Cantina at the Cantina
she meets up with a client who she was
fetching an object for and uh the person
who she meets up with has kind of kind
of double crossed her a little bit
there's someone from the Empire there
and the Imperial officer uh kind of
asked you if you if you'd like to bribe
them for them to you know keep kind of
quiet about seeing you and yeah so
there's some there's a little bit of
dialogue Choice did it seem pretty deep
or was it pretty context like hey you've
got two options you can bribe or you
don't have to bribe it seemed
does seem like the choices that you make
whether it's bribe don't bribe lie don't
lie do have they impact kind of your
reputation which is apparently the
biggest system in the game is your your
reputation and how different gangs or
organizations or Syndicate CEO
um so you can either bribe or not bribe
this Imperial officer ultimately and the
gameplay I saw they chose not to bribe
which caused their like it's almost kind
of like a Grand Theft Auto wanted level
to kind of Rise oh interesting yeah so
then she's you know booking it out of
the Cantina what people are chasing her
down gets into her Starship and um you
go seamlessly from these locations to
just going into space and they're like
dog fights with Tie fighters and driving
through Rubble you can like find a clear
space and go into you know hyperdrive so
it was it was pretty impressive honestly
so it did you get an idea of the scale
of it because I think I saw that this at
least they're saying this is the first
truly open world Star Wars game but what
does that mean especially if you can go
to outer space that seems big yeah
space outside of it and then entering
another planet's orbit
um but it still seems pretty big I mean
compared to every other take on a Star
Wars game that we've seen
um this one seems quite a bit bigger
yeah is it pretty focused in terms of
combat is it pretty focused on that like
third person shooter style gameplay I
mean is there like melee weapons I think
you said you can get in close to but
there's no lightsabers yeah no
lightsabers no melee weapons that I saw
okay um you never know and they'll
surprise you but sure yeah just blasters
just the third person shooting
um and it seems like it's going to be
one of those games where you can really
you can play it stealthy you can decide
that you just want to go in you know
kind of guns blazing and something that
I noticed too is like whenever the
person who was playing got caught and
the hands-off preview that I saw
um there was kind of like a pause where
the person was like hey what are you
doing and you it's time slows a little
bit and you can kind of choose to shoot
first or not and so it seems like that
might be system when you say not like
flea or does it seem like maybe like
dialogue options you can kind of talk
your way out of it it seemed almost like
I don't know if dialogue options would
have popped up because he he ended up
shooting yeah but it definitely slowed
down and it maybe it'd be one of those
situations to where if you don't shoot
something else would have happened okay
so it sounds kind of like what Metal
Gear Solid 5 did when you get caught
time slows and you have that second to
react whether you should hide whatever
it might be
um that sounds that sounds cool that
sounds really ambitious I don't know any
final thoughts
um I guess for those of you who are
wondering where in the Star Wars
timeline it takes place because it is a
lot
um this one is actually between Empire
Strikes Back and Return of the Jedi okay
I don't know how much we're going to see
of like the main Trio or anything like
that we do see Han um in carbonite but I
think that was in the trailer that we
saw already
um but yeah so I mean it's it's
interesting we could potentially
actually see you know Luke Skywalker in
his transition to uh you know wearing
the the all black outfit phase I I don't
know so it's there's a lot to be excited
about but even if they don't lean into
that even if they don't you know Go full
Skywalker with it
um there seems to be a lot that just
gives it its own identity
um and it should be a lot of fun for
people who just like a good stealth game
yeah any idea when it comes out did they
tell you that or were they pretty vague
they said 2024
um but it's a big game yeah we'll see
yeah well that's been Star Wars Outlaws
thank you so much for tuning in and make
sure to check out our other Impressions
from summer game Fest and Beyond but
with that we'll see you next time